-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-winning actress you know
from her work in the films
"Walk the Line" and "Legally Blonde,"
as well as the hit series
"Big Little Lies" and "The Morning Show."
She stars in the new movie "Your Place or Mine,"
which premieres on Netflix February 10th.
Please welcome back to the show Reese Witherspoon, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here!
-Look at Fred playing the drums. -Isn't it?
He's just a man of many trades. -And perfume.
He has his own man perfume. -Yeah. Well, I don't think
-It's amazing. -it's just for men. Right, Fred?
-Can I have some? -Yes, it's for everybody.
[ Laughter ] -Okay, so, okay, okay.
He's always for everybody. -It's unisex.
-Yeah, absolutely. -That's so good!
-[ Laughs ] It's so nice to have you here
and I'm very excited about "The Morning Show."
You just wrapped Season 3. -Yes!
-And I'm very excited about that.
And I have to imagine, is this the longest thing
you've ever worked on? -It actually is.
This has been five years of my life,
three seasons, ten episodes each.
Jennifer Aniston and I were talking about it the other day.
It's like making five movies, so it's like we made 15 movies.
[ Laughter ] -Yeah, it's very impressive.
-Which was fun. -Fifteen movies is really, yeah.
-We made 15 movies together. -And you added Jon Hamm
to the cast this year, one of our favorites here.
-He's so great. -That must be a...
very easy person to be around.
-So talented, so smart, and, off the top of his head,
really funny, just comes up with really funny stuff.
-I'm deeply -- I'm always deeply angry
at how funny Jon Hamm is because people who look like Jon Hamm
shouldn't also be funny. [ Laughter ]
-He's really -- Yeah, it's true.
-Yeah. -It's a real drag.
-Yeah, he's really, really funny.
-Yeah. [ Laughter ]
So, I didn't remember this until I saw the photo,
but you and Jennifer Aniston worked together before.
Twenty years ago, you played her younger sister on "Friends."
-I was her younger on "Friends."
[ Cheering and applause ] -Now...what --
-Yes, and the funny storyline was
I started dating Ross because she and Ross were
"on a break." -Yeah.
I do recall hearing that at some point
about the two of them.
-And she gets really jealous and she's like,
"You can't date Ross," and I was like, "I can't?
The only thing I can't have is dairy."
[ Laughter ] -Whoo!
I still remember the line. -You're still off-book.
-I still --
Their writing was so good on that show,
so it's really memorable.
I have all sorts of funny, famous "Friends" lines
that are stuck in my head. Don't y'all?
-Yeah, of course. -Everybody has a favorite.
-Do you remember what it felt like
to walk onto that set? Because, at the time,
it was already a phenomenon.
-Oh, my gosh, yeah. So, I was terrified.
I was out of my body. I was -- My body was there
and then my head and my brain was somewhere else.
I just had a baby. -Wow!
-Yeah. So, that's how I know it was 23 years ago,
because, now, my baby is 23.
But walking into Central Perk... -Yeah.
-...that main coffee place
and sitting on the couch, I was like,
"Oh, my God, I can't believe this is happening.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, there's Joey. Oh, my God."
And then wait! Joey said to me,
"How you doing?"
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't just say that to everybody.
[ Applause ]
-You're right. No, but it was so fun.
It was so -- I was terrified, but Aniston was so sweet to me.
She was like, "They don't care if you mess up.
They actually like it better when you mess up."
-Oh, that's a very nice thing to hear
before you do any bit of acting.
-Any live show or whatever. It wasn't live,
but it was recorded in front of this many people.
Maybe more. -Exactly. It's a big deal.
I mean, I didn't do a ton of sitcom work,
but the first thing I ever did was in a sitcom,
the first line I had on television.
-Hold on. I think I was on your very first "SNL."
-You were on my very first "SNL," yeah.
-Okay, so, I was the host of "SNL"...
-Yep.
-...on your very first day on "SNL."
-That is absolutely -- September 29, 2001.
How about that? [ Cheering and applause ]
Reese Witherspoon and -- -I remember.
-And Alicia Keys. -Yeah, Alicia Keys. Oh, my gosh.
And then Amy Poehler's first day, too.
-Yep, it was Amy Poehler's first day.
-And I'll never forget meeting you and Amy and thinking,
"Oh, my God, these people are so talented.
This is going to be so good."
-That was a rare case, where, no matter how nervous you were,
I promise I was more nervous on that day.
[ Laughter ] -Aww.
-It was a trip. -But what a dream,
what a dream, that you've had this incredible journey.
-Oh, thank you.
I'm glad that we're making this about me, I really do.
[ Laughter ] -Well.
I do want to talk about your --
Well, you are so loved by so many people
-Oh, my God. -and the fact that like --
Like, I saw Paul at --
[ Cheering and applause ]
You are. You're just really deeply respected.
Everybody finds you so hysterical,
but also you're just a genuinely nice human,
so, like, Fred comes and plays the drums
because you're just a genuinely great person.
-This is so -- And it's so hard for me to say this right now
because you're so mean off-camera.
[ Laughter ]
But, no, it's a real trip when you --
-I just don't want you to tell the truth about how awful I was
on "SNL." You're like, "Oh, God."
-No, God, it was wonderful.
-It was tough. -I mean, it was also, you know,
if we're really talking about that day,
the craziest thing about that show is
it was two weeks after 9/11. -Yeah.
-It was, you know, this insane time here,
and it was also really grounding
to be able to go to work
and actually do something for people.
-It was terrifying. Yeah, it was a terrifying time
and we were in New York City and it was right after 9/11
and we were like -- and Lorne was so adamant
that people needed to laugh. -Yes.
-And I think he was right.
And he brought all these firefighters on
and Paul Simon was there. It was amazing.
-It was. And I felt --
[ Applause ] Yeah, it was a really --
[ Cheering ] -You did a really great job.
-And, when you left "SNL," when I left,
there was a producer named Kenny Aymong
who used to do this wonderful thing where he would give you
the ticket of your first show and your last show, framed...
-Aww. -...so I've got my Reese Witherspoon ticket
-Oh, my God! -on my office wall right now.
-That's awesome. -I think about you every day...
-Oh, my gosh. -...very fondly.
Not in a creepy way, just like -- yeah.
[ Laughter ] Just like a normal, healthy,
the way people should think
about Reese Witherspoon every day.
[ Laughter ]
-But, you know, I feel really lucky
to be part of people's lives for so long.
And the fact that people watch my movies and my TV shows
and it's like that's a big gift, to have people enjoy your work
and have a career where people watched you for so long
and I feel really personally about it.
I just ran into a chocolate store
because I'm, like, trying to buy chocolates
for my kids for Valentine's Day and this girl goes,
"Oh, my God! Are you Reese Witherspoon?!"
I was like, "Yeah! [ Laughter ]
I am!" And she's like -- she's like, "Oh, my God!
I'm an acting student. What should I do?"
And I was like, "Okay, first, you do this, then you do that.
Then you audition your butt off.
You're not going to get every job,
but just work your tail off." And then I thought,
"I'm so, so, so lucky to have people like that in my life."
I'm really lucky. I'm lucky. -Well, it's also -- it's so nice
to use those moments
because, again, you have them and sometimes they happen
when you maybe don't have the time or focus
you want to give to a person, but it's so --
Anytime you do -- Anytime you actually take a breath
and realize, oh, you would be nothing if it wasn't
for people like this who actually care about your work.
-Yeah, I'd be nothing without -- -To give them something back.
-Like, yeah. I have a movie coming on Netflix.
It's my very first Netflix movie.
-Very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I just -- I thought, you know, I was like --
I really -- I set a goal.
I was like, "I really want to be on a Netflix movie,"
because I think it's so important
that so many people can't leave their house.
-Yep. -They can't go places.
They're taking care of kids. They have older parents.
They have -- They work their tails off,
and then they're exhausted, and all they want to do
is just sit on the couch with potato chips like this.
So I'm really excited. It's a really great, positive movie.
-I want to talk about it after this break.
I also want to say, to me, it's deeply funny that you --
When that person at the chocolate shop saw you,
you were doing something very out of a rom-com,
which was --
The idea of, like, meeting Reese Witherspoon
when she runs into a chocolate shop.
-Right. I'm running. -To buy candy for Halloween.
Not for Halloween. Valentine's Day.
-I was actually -- I was late for your show
because I was buying chocolate.
I was like, "Pull over!"
And, like, with the full big box, it's a heart.
It was fully a rom-com moment. -I love it.
Well, I mean, it comes natural to some people, yeah.
I want to ask about the movie.
We'll be right back with more from Reese Witherspoon.